markus söder hat sich ja sicherlich was
gedacht dabei auch die staatskanzlei in
münchen ist ja repräsentativ seit franz
josef strauß sie hat bauen lassen
aber dort vorzufahren werden sie sich
erinnern an den g 7 gipfel in ellmau als
dieses bild mit obama auf der bank mit
den bergen im hintergrund um die welt
gegen da hat bayern schon was zu bieten
und das nützt markus söder
natürlich das ist heute repräsentativ
dass es der zufall will dass es jetzt
gerade in diese zeit der diskussion um
den kanzlerkandidaten kommt das kommt
ihm natürlich entgegen und ich kann mir
vorstellen
er hat eingeladen frau merkel kann da
gar nicht absagen
und jetzt liefert sie ihm ob sie will
oder nicht aber ich glaube immer mehr
will sie das auch eine große bühne